I'm just a girl getting ready to go on live TV.
And I know I said that I would chop my hair off for fashion.
I slightly regretted that decision
when I saw just how short my bangs were this morning.
So if you see me wearing a hat more than usual,
that's why.
Got picked up at 6:00am this morning and we drove into the city.
I can't believe that I'm gonna be on the today show in a few hours.
Had a quick fitting for the outfits that I was gonna wear,
and then I got my hair sorted,
did my makeup before I got changed and did the last final touches.
I slept so bad the night before because I was so nervous for this,
but before I knew it, I was going backstage,
getting mic'd up, going through all of my demo steps.
Couple minutes before we were live,
I went into the studio and then it was time to film.
The kids and lucky were watching from home
and he got so emotional when he saw me get on.
It went so much quicker than I thought,
and I can't believe that this is real life.
And after a quick outfit change,
it was time to go home and talk to my kids all about it.